JUDGE JEANINE: WE HEARD FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT THE TOP OF
THE HOUR AT THE WEEK AHEAD COULD
BE A BAD ONE IN THIS ONGOING
BATTLE AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT FROM THE
FRONT LINES IS THE STAND SECOND
TEAR JOY HER HELTS AND HUMAN
SERVICES, ADMIRAL BRETT GIROIR.
ADMIRAL.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
THINGS.
THE ISSUE OF THE TESTING.
THE ABBOTT TEST GIVES YOU A
POSITIVE TEST WITHIN MINUTES AND
A NEGATIVE WITHIN 4 MINUTES.
I KNOW WE -- WITHIN 14 MINUTES.
HOW LONG BEFORE EVERYONE CAN GET
ONE OF THESE?
>> TESTING HAS RAMPED UP IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED HISTORIC WAY.
WE TESTED.55 MILLION 1.55
MILLION SAMPLES.
THE ABBOTT MACHINE IS TOASTER
SIZE AND THERE ARE THOUSANDS OUT
THERE EVERY DAY BEING USED TO
TEST FOR FLU.
50,000 TESTS ARE BEING SHIPPED
EVERY DAY AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE BEEN GOOD TO WORK WITH
US GOING TO THE HOTPOTS WHERE WE
NEED THEM THE MOST.
WE SENT 1,200 MACHINES.
AND TO RURAL PLACES LIKE ALASKA
WHERE THEY NEED A SMALL PORTABLE
DEVICE.
YOU WILL SEE TESTS POURING IN
THIS WEEK.
JUDGE JEANINE: HOW LONG BEFORE
YOU THINK ANYBODY WHO WANTS THE
TEST WILL BE ABLE TO GET A TEST.
>> WE’LL HAVE 250,000 TO 300,000
A WEEK.
THIS IS STILL A LIMITED SOURCE.
WE ARE NOT AT THE STAGE YET
WHERE ANYBODY WHO WANTS A TEST
WILL GET A TEST.
BUT PEOPLE WHO NEED A TEST WILL
GET A TEST.
HOSPITAL WORKERS, PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELDERLY.
WE HAVE GOT IT.
JUDGE JEANINE: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THE ANTIBODY TEST.
IT WILL TELL US IF YOU HAVE HAD
IT, AND NOW YOU HAVE A
RESISTANCE TO IT.
AND IF THAT’S TRUE, YOU CAN TELL
ME.
AND IF MAYBE YOU WILL NEVER GET
IT, THAT YOU HAVE A NATURAL
ANTIBODY OR NATURAL RESISTANCE.
>> THIS IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT
TYPE OF TEST AND ONE THAT COULD
BE SCALED TO THE MILLIONS AND
TENS OF MILLIONS VERY QUICKLY.
IT DOES TELL YOU IF YOU HAVE AN
ANTIBODY IT MEANS YOUR BODY HAS
SEEN THE VIRUS AND HAS RESPONDED
TO IT.
THIS IS VERY, VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND KINDS OF WHAT
THE DISEASE DID.
DID IT ATTACK 1%.
5%, 20% OF AMERICA?
IT WILL LET PEOPLE KNOW WITH
ASSURANCE YOU WILL BE IMMUNE THE
NEXT TIME IT COMES AROUND.
AND IF YOU ARE NOT, THOSE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO TAKE
SPECIAL PRECAUTIONS.
JUDGE JEANINE: SOME PEOPLE HAVE
HAD IT, AND THEY ARE
ASYMPTOMATIC, THEY DON’T KNOW
THEY HAD IT, AND NOW THEY
DEVELOPED AN IMMUNITY.
>> THIS IS RIGHT ON THE HORIZON.
THERE ARE TESTS OUT THERE IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
BUT I WANT TO CAUTION EVERYONE.
IF THE TEST SAYS YOU ARE IMMUNE,
YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE IMMUNE SO
YOU DON’T HAVE RISKY BEHAVIOR.
WE ARE TESTING THE PRECISION OF
THESE TESTS TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE PERFECT OR AS GOOD AS THEY
CAN BE.
YOU WILL SEE THEM STARTING TO
ROLL OUT THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS.
JUDGE JEANINE: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THE SEROLOGY TEST, THE BLOOD
TEST.
HOW DOES THAT PLAY WITH THE
OTHER TWO TESTS?
>> THE BLOOD TEST, THE SEROLOGY
TEST IS THE ANTIBODY TEST.
YOU CAN ALSO DO A FINGER PRICK
AND GET A RESULT WITHIN MINUTES.
THIS IS TRIED AND TRUE
TECHNOLOGY.
JUDGE JEANINE: NOW THE MASKS.
WE HAVE TWO CONTROVERSIES.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WASN’T
GOING TO WEAR THE MASK.
BUT THE SAME DATE PRESIDENT SAID
HE WASN’T GOING TO WEAR IT HE
JUST HAD A TEST TO SAY HE
DOESN’T HAVE IT.
IF THE POINT OF THE MASK IS TO
PREVENT YOU FROM SPREADING IT TO
SOMEONE ELSE --
>> I WILL GIVE YOU AN HONORARY
M.D. DEGREE BECAUSE YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE PURPOSE OF THE MASK IS TO
PROTECT OTHER PEOPLE FROM
YOURSELF SPREADING IT TO THEM.
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS HE’S
NEGATIVE SO HE WON’T SPREAD IT
TO ANYONE ELSE.
YOU HAVE GOT IT SUMMED UP.
JUDGE JEANINE: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THE HYDRO CHLOROQUINE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I KNOW
PEOPLE WHO WERE TAKING IT.
PEOPLE WHO NEVER HAD THE COVID
AS FAR AS THEY KNOW.
IF IT IS FDA APPROVED, IT’S NOT
APPROVED FOR THE COVID, BUT IT’S
BEING USED OFF LABEL.
IS THERE A HARM TO IT BEING USED
OFF LABEL?
I SUSPECT YOU WILL SAY IT
DEPENDS ON WHO YOU ARE.
BUT WHY NOT TRY SOMETHING IF
IT’S NOT GOING TO HURT YOU.
>> IT CAN BE USED OFF LABEL AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF THE EXPERIENCE
WITH IT.
WITH ANY DRUG THERE IS NO SUCH
THING AS A FREE LUNCH.
THERE IS ALWAYS POTENTIAL SIDE
EFFECTS.
WE KNOW THERE CAN BE SIDE
EFFECTS OF HIGH -- OF HYDRO CHLO
AS YOU KNOW, THERE ARE SOME
DATA, NOT PROVEN OR
SCIENTIFICALLY ABSOLUTELY 100%.
BUT THERE IS SUGGESTIVE EVIDENCE
IT CAN BE HELPFUL.
THIS IS A DECISION BETWEEN A
PHYSICIAN AND PATIENT WHO GOES
ON IT UNDERSTANDING THE RISK AND
BENEFITS.
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF BENEFITS WITH IN
OTHER DRUGS OUT THERE, MANY
PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING TO USE THE
DRUGS.
IT’S A REASONABLE DECISION.
IT’S BETWEEN THE PATIENT AND THE
PHYSICIAN.
THE DATA ARE SUGGESTIVE.
NOT ABSOLUTELY TRUE, BUT
SUGGESTIVE.
JUDGE JEANINE: I UNDERSTAND
DR. FAUCI AND I RESPECT HIM, BUT
HE WORKS OFF DATE AND SCIENCE
AND NUMBERS.
TO THE ORDINARY AMERICAN WHO
DOESN’T KNOW HIS HEAD.
THEY WILL SAY, PEOPLE ARE DYING
FROM THIS.
HOW MANY DAYS BEFORE WE THINK
THIS STARTS, YOU KNOW, THE
SPREAD STARTS TO SLOW?
>> I THINK WE REALLY ARE GETTING
SOME EVIDENCE THAT THE SPREAD IS
STARTING TO SLOW IN MANY AREAS.
CLEARLY WASHINGTON AND
CALIFORNIA ARE DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB, AND WE ARE SEEING THE
BENEFITS OF THEIR EARLY ACTION
ABOUT SLOW CAN THE SPREAD FROM
THE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
WE ARE EVEN SEEING SOME
OPTIMISTIC SIGNS IN NEW YORK.
BUFF WHAT I WANT YOU -- AND I
KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND IT AND YOUR
VIEWERS -- THE ILLNESS WE SEE
NOW, THE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEATHS ARE THE
RESULT OF INFECTIONS THAT TOOK
PLACE TWO OR THREE WEEKS AGO.
YOU WILL SEE BY ALL MODELS AND
PREDICTIONS THAT UNFORTUNATELY
THE MORTALITY WILL GO UP THIS
WEEK AND THE HOSPITALIZATIONS,
BUT WE ARE SEEING SIGNS -- IF
YOU HIS BE TO WHAT THE PRESIDENT
AND VICE PRESIDENT SAID, 15
DAYS, NOW 30 DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD, WE’LL COME OUT OF IT
STRONG.
BUT WE’LL HAVE A DIFFICULT WEEK
AHEAD OF US BECAUSE WE ARE
DEALING WITH THE INFECTIONS THAT
OCCURRED TWO OR THREE WEEKS AGO.
JUDGE JEANINE: I’M IN NEW YORK
CITY RIGHT NOW.
GIVEN THE LOCATION OF WHERE YOU
ARE, IT SEEMS TO HAVE HIT NEW
YORK SO QUICKLY AND SEEMS TO
HAVE MOVED TO OTHER STATES.
WE MAY SEE THE SPREAD SPREADING
IN OTHER STATES.
DOESN’T IT DEPEND UPON WHERE YOU
LIVE?
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHERE WE ARE SEEING THE BIG
POPULATION CENTERS IS WHERE
GLOBAL TOURISM CAME EVEN BEFORE
THE CHINESE ANNOUNCED THE VIRUS
WAS THERE, THERE WERE PROBABLY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF SWRILS
TORES OUT OF THOSE AREAS THAT
CAME -- VISITORS OF THOSE AREAS
THAT CAME TO THE UNITED STATES.
NEW YORK IS FIRST WITH NEW
JERSEY.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT DETROIT.
AND NEW ORLEANS.
YOU MAY SEETHER POCKETS.
THE -- YOU MAY SEE OTHER
POCKETS.
BUT CLEARLY NEW YORK IS RIGHT
OUT IN FRONT WITH NEW JERSEY.
I TALKED TO THEIR DOCTORS, THEIR
NURSES, THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH
PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
AND I WANT TO SALUTE THEM FOR
DOING A HEROIC, GREAT JOB.
I CAN’T ADMIRE THEM ANY MORE
THAN I DO NOW.
JUDGE JEANINE: ADMIRAL BRETT
GIROIR, WE ADMIRE YOU.
AND WE ARE NOT UNDERMINEDFUL OF
THE FACT THAT YOU GUYS ARE GOING